you know since I was a child I always
had a you know a desire for jury like it
represents a lot of things you know
individuality royalty you know because I
would like to look at myself like a king
so this Metro boomin and i'ma show you
something my druid is booming pieces
this is one of the first pieces I got my
boy Elliott honey
I give my idea all the time when we come
up with a design for everything I told
my one that just a booming like just a
little like comic book like the pie or
whatever I'm very meticulous with
designer jewelry you know just as
producing songs or getting dressed
anything I was in stood up for like
three days putting together lowlife week
in the future
it was just a moment I remember so
vividly like I was so happy about that
song I love that song and yeah I was
just wearing a chain in the studios I
don't know about everybody else but for
me when I buy jewelry they're like the
trophies so when I got everything like I
know what was going on why I got it I
just got this job talk to me like a week
ago it's all white stones everything is
white white gold had a cut like this
triangle diamond like on the mouthpiece
ball I definitely always grew up loving
Star Wars it's definitely a big thing
for my family a lot of stuff there's new
stuff we've been doing I saw like 3d and
I got these right here
my company label you know booming attic
I got this one first CEO on about it and
then I got one reverse I rose gold with
white gold on top I already like this
[ __ ] color stones that's good ain't
worth that
the so I see boys I got this made when
Gucci was locked up that's his old label
original so you know I was a big fan
during those days so and then just
everything with me at him in my career I
just wanted to get that like that's a
simple appreciation for quite Voges to
me one day you know bad and boozy and
coach one platinum and everything so
they got some Chinese made even gave me
one of you you know exodus' family my
brother cash in a weekend cash I got
this for me I got this cuz I'm from San
Luis so I got the coroner's logo his
diamond white go with the rose gold on
the outline of the sta so I got this
cross because you know it's definitely
what means the most to me I just want to
get some like that subtle I could just
always have got this lightning bolt got
thought everyone today like I'm og Eddie
just had this one day I liked it it has
a couple means something like another
eye watching over your assumption this
actually I didn't designed to have him
do he actually already had it made and I
saw him put on Instagram one day way it
was just like you know this what's going
on he mix and match so I feel like it's
like dressing up it's not all about just
throwing all this [ __ ] on it once I feel
like everyone's if all this stuff is so
custom I want you to appreciate and
focus on the detail you're not gonna
appreciate this as much if I got like
four other chains on with it you know
everything is a process so it's not
allowed just bought a bunch of jewelry
at one time over a couple years few
years just you know piece by piece so my
sister's like the first ring I got from
was this wedding band
got a rose woman from a one-time and
then I remember what time you show me
this this is a pinkie ring but there's
three rings they actually like welded
together some [ __ ] this pinkie ring it's
one of the other first rings I have this
ring same thing but this is three rings
of these rings just a few of them
original we're like four maybe five but
swing both hands now I just don't like
to own my hand I got these tennis vs
were some of the first ones I got from
these are white is all white gold with
emerald cuts definitely entities just
some difference like these are just
straight pointers like he's probably 25
points or so I might just wear these two
on this arm and wear one or the other
I had 3ds I had gave one of my
girlfriend cuz I love these two a rose
gold these are two of my favorites these
are 40 pointers sometimes I might put a
couple of these on it just tuck them in
just for like just accents rose gold
this is like a 35-point of white chain
it's one of the longer ones and this one
just a little chain just a tiny one you
know just more subtle you know just put
my cross on there sometimes or just
throw it on top of whatever I don't know
nice outside to show late one time it's
just going so crazy and then I went to
the front of the stage and then I
remember I just went back to a DJ booth
and I just remember looking down and
necklace was on but it's like hanging
from my neck and my shirt independent
was on there anymore and I was early on
before I had this much so that was like
one of my two or three pieces so yeah I
took a hell on that one that day but you
know I got insurance as a kid I had like
watches true you know high school I was
into G socks even though the watches
they were having McDonald's and Burger
King and [ __ ] like you put those on
without
assume you know this rosin right here
this is a Rolex
this is 41 the presidential Roscoe some
diamonds around the bezel this Rolex
right here it's the newest watch I got
this is a Rolex this is a Jubilee the
Jubilee band is something where they're
doing and it's smaller this is my
smallest watch but it's not ice down the
face but it's just nice it's more subtle
this right here just a patek philippe
white gold you know straight from Ivy on
this
definitely a trophy right here this is a
ap automata skeleton white gold
it causes skeleton because you could see
right through it this watch I want is my
favorite watch this one I wear every day
this is a skeleton tool this rose gold
but it's plain just a couple cartier
braces the song let's put that bed a lot
of times on front of it or whatever this
is the first case that guy got this case
you know you hold the Rings up there and
all that and I could keep all my pieces
in bed just so the air and the dirt just
don't get on while I'm not wearing my
stuff this is a velvet case I actually
got from Elliot actually designed that
the shop is their own case it's probably
my favorite case just cuz it's so mobile
just roll it out so many pockets in it
put a lot of stuff in here
I still lose the time watch case it
holds three just fry the best watch case
everyday you stopped in the airport
about this it's just what it is you know
what it's my boy right here you know le
I'd say the world famous you know
infamous Elliot he's always starting so
new so now he's got this this is a
really one my favorite pieces period you
know he's got his name and he's got the
tennis train like attached we connect so
well because he even on a music level I
feel like I'm always trying to be
innovative or just do what everybody's
not doing or what's next he's the exact
same way to do every piece that he got
represents something like trophy trophy
basically like you told me every time he
buys a new piece of jewelry
it makes a newbie and the title of the
beat is the new piece of jewelry no on
pop ain't gonna come on bro yo Metro
three times I'm here with my boy Elliot
hobby Ani and my boy gunner star you
know we just went over some of these
pieces and you know we out of here
[Music]